Well there he is folks! The future of the
New York Knicks.
What--who, that guy?
Yeah, the rookie… “What’s His Name.”
Uhh.. Chris Taps Poor Jangis.
No it’s KRISTAPS PORZINGIS, and he SUCKS.
He sucks? Then why’d we draft him?
Because he doesn’t suck, okay? He’s supposed
to be the Latvian Dirk Nowitzki.
Not according to Phil Jackson.
Yeah, Phil who thinks this kid’s gonna be
the next Shawn Bradley!
But he drafted ‘em!
Yeah and we won’t even know for years!
That’s right, they say he’s two to three
years away at best.
You gotta let ‘em develop!
Two to three years until what? Until we find
out he’s Shawn Bradley?
Two to three years until he’s STILL two
to three years away.
Two to three years is FOREVER!
HE COULD BE DEAD BY THE TIME HE’S GOOD!
Porzingis! Porzingis!
Is he the Latvian Dirk?
Or Latvian Shawn?
Porzingis Porzingis! Is he the Latvian Dirk?
Yeah, no way. This kid is the Latvian Shawn
Bradley. I’m tellin’ ya.
No, this guy’s got a much higher ceiling.
Chyeah and a much lower floor.
Woah woah woah, how low are we talkin’ about
here?
Like, below sea level.
Like bottomless pit!
He’s too skinny.
He’s too frickin white if you ask me.
He’s too skinny and white!
Porzingis! Porzingis! Is he the Latvian Dirk?
Or Latvian Shawn?
Porzingis Porzingis! Is he the Latvian Dirk?
No, he’s the Latvian Shawn!
No, he’s the Latvian Dirk!
Shawn!
Dirk!
Well maybe we should wait and see.
What young Kristaps turns out to be.
Labels like Dirk and Shawn are a burden.
Plus, he’s obviously the next Patrick Ewing!
Porzingis! Porzingis! Is he the Latvian Dirk?
Or Latvian Shawn?
Porzingis Porzingis! Is he the Latvian Dirk?
Well I guess all we can do is what to see
if this guy turns out to be Dirk!
Or Shawn!
Or Dirk!
Or Patrick Ewing.